la fin d'une ère la fin de la fameuse
doctrine mitterrand voilà comment cette
décision de l'exécutif concernant
l'arrestation de ces anciens militants
italiens réfugié en france depuis plus
de 30 ans est perçue par l'opposition
politique mais pas seulement tout
d'abord un peu d'histoire les brigades
rouges sont nés en 1970 seesus l'extrême
gauche italienne ce groupe choisi la
lutte armée comme méthode de
protestation le groupe s'organise pour
critiquer la modération du parti
communiste italien très puissant à
l'époque et se développe autour des
luttes révolutionnaires
il existe beaucoup d'autres groupes de
l'ultra gauche mais c'est le principal
leur période d'activité correspond aux
années plomb italiennes une période de
fortes tensions politiques entre
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite qui
débouchent sur des violences et des
actes terroristes qui font des dizaines
de victimes comme l'ancien président du
conseil
aldo moro séquestré exécuté en 1978
l'extrême droite ne fut pas en reste
durant cette période également
on lui doit notamment le terrible
attentat de la gare de bologne qui
détient le triste record des années de
plomb avec pas moins de 85 morts et des
centaines de blessés
condamné en italie la plupart de ces
activistes décide de se réfugier en
france suite notamment aux positions de
françois mitterrand fraîchement élu le
président souligne l'attachement de la
france aux droits de l'homme et affirme
sa volonté est d'accueillir ceux qui
seraient poursuivis pour des raisons
politiques
en 1985 le chef de l'état s'engage même
à ne pas extrader vers l'italie les
membres d'organisations terroristes est
d'extrême gauche qui n'auraient pas de
sang sur les mains des mots qui ont
terni les relations franco italiennes
pendant plus de trente ans rome
réclamant leur extradition pour pouvoir
les juger
emmanuel macron a mis fin à ces tensions
la semaine dernière je n'ai strictement
aucun état d'âme
le président de la république depuis le
début de la mandature est en relation
étroite avec nos amis italiens qu'ils
souhaitent que soit enfin
jugé ce terroriste je suis fier de
participer à cette décision qui je
l'espère permettra à l'italie après 40
ans de tourner une page de son histoire
qui est maculée de chant alors dans quel
but de cette décision si soudaine a été
prise c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser près de quarante ans plus tard la
prescription est possible quoi qu'il en
soit les autorités françaises sont
passées à l'acte en or et ans cet ancien
brigadiste sur la liste et 10 non
transmises
ap aaron deux se sont rendus 1 est
toujours recherché enzo calvetti par
l'intermédiaire de son avocat jean louis
chalanset dénonce une trahison de la
france pour lui c'est la vengeance
d'état de la part d'états italien avec
la complicité de l'état français avec
des mensonges pro peuvent prospérer par
garde des sceaux français qui est parle
de 400 morts des brigades rouges la soul
aux missions de de ce ministre qui prend
tous les morts de l'extrême droite
italienne et que jamais les brigades
rouges les autres groupes de lutte armée
n'ont causé la mort de quatre cents
personnes donc c'est un mensonge éhonté
un avis partagé par l'opposition
politique à commencer par jean luc
mélenchon sur twitter le leader de la
france insoumise implore le président
français de ne pas extrader ces réfugiés
italiens un acte de vengeance plutôt que
de justice selon lui plusieurs l
association des droits de l'homme sont
également montés au créneau
revirement inquiétant de la france pour
les réfugiés italiens s'en prendre à des
femmes et hommes qui vivent dans notre
pays depuis plus de 40 ans jugé en
italie dans des conditions dictées par
les contingences de l'époque
ce n'est pas fair acte de justice ne pas
faire acte de justice était surtout
satisfaire le nouveau gouvernement
italien en effet lorsque matteo salvini
était au pouvoir
la demande d'extradition est restée
vaine l'arrivée de mario draghi a tout
changé
certains parlent d'arrangement politique
d'autres de décision historique
à chacun son point de vue mais à un an
des présidentielles
les spéculations vont bon train